bon bah présente à moi - ca zac élevé
ils viennent c'est le voilà quelqu'un de
bien un jeune qui croient simplement à
nouveau lui d'assister un rush tout en
haut les assises c'est le rush regarde
les autres allaient venir bernard riou
avance pas à pas l'euro après rien
ledger pour pour même et servir comédie
lie à monsieur ah koon et professionnel
il ya monsieur dallas notre collègue
monsieur médard ici on dit monsieur le
respect et la première valeur de l'
académie des dalons depuis 2013 des
jeunes de 18 à 25 ans en situation de
fragilité sociale et économique trouve
ici un nouvel élan 3 - d'internât avec
beaucoup de stress ou si des fois
ben parce que si on nous avait vécu des
moments forts très fortes comme le
surpassement de soi même comme et pas
besoin peu un examen on a fait de la
plongée sous-marine on a fait du
canyoning et s'éteint
ave le stress vraiment beaucoup de
stress mais banal à pour la surmonter un
stress et son outil permettra zone des
représentants a adopté ici
l'objectif donc c'est vraiment une
première il y en aura d'autres et
j'espère que les films qui vont vous est
présentée qui sont des courts métrages à
ces cours vont pouvoir après faire leur
chemin
ses dalons ont travaillé sur des faits
de société
mais avec leurs mots ils donnent leur
vision de quoi faire avancer les choses
et le réseau de côté sa folle non et
elle avoue daniel battu on sorte à
offrir
il est fier points avant tout me cache
pas la vérité mais me les faire aussi
pour ben collett parce qu'il s'était pas
banal à 100 est venu nous tout terrain
n'aurait pas été si en fin de compte
parce qu'ici nous dépend des années le
contrat d'engagement de l'académie est
de 12 mois dont trois mois d'internât de
ces semaines
né un projet porté par ses jeunes qui
produit quelque chose d'utile à la
société
[Applaudissements]
nous revenons au contraire beaucoup de
fierté parce que là où un mur mais
reçoit notamment la tête haute du monde
en chemin garde fièrement comme avant
parce qu'avant d'être quand même normal
mais aujourd'hui combien y'a bien
maintenue costume cravate et mais
représentait le conseil général d du
département la baie de manille war main
comme si voix la prochaine étape
neuf mois de service civique dont l'une
des 80 associations et 20 services de
collectivités
aussitôt le spectacle terminé comme un
seul homme tout le monde se met à ronger
vivre et agir un savoir être qui est
beau à voir et c'est un projet crient
montent et qui doit et qui décide donc
en fait ça permet aussi lorsqu'on tient
à une idée de l'accompagner et nous
d'être un peu plus exigeants après sur
la qualité de ce qui peut être rendu
l'âme hier
ben moi me projette à moins de devenir
agent technique de déchetteries et
surtout ne voudrait bien remercier mon
cousin tony baleiniers qui étaient là
vos mains parce que tout cela c'est
grâce à lui et jusqu'à la famille sera
reconnaissante envers ce mouvement
[Musique]